good morning Millennials um
happy Monday I guess it doesn't really
feel like a happy Monday um it's been a
very sad and somber weekend in this
country um yeah it feels weird to be
coming on here but we have a lot to talk
about and we wanted to dedicate this
episode to just discussing um a lot of
things that happen over the weekend the
weekend for me was just totally consumed
by what's been happening it's been
really stressful it's been a stressful
and challenging time for the country but
more specifically for the black
community and you know Jackie and I just
wanted to reiterate like our hearts are
just so heavy with what's been going on
and we really um just wanted to dedicate
this episode to talking about the
current state of the world I really
didn't think about anything other than
George Floyd during the entire weekend
I've just like been watching videos
podcasts just consuming so much content
about it I'm just trying to for the show
obviously get as much information as
possible but also just for myself as a
human being yeah definitely I spent the
weekend the same way watching videos
reading trying to get a better
understanding of what's going on and
what has been going on um so it really
just doesn't feel right for us to do our
typical show today um the country is
just it's heartbreaking our hearts are
heavy with what's with what's been going
on especially as it relates to what the
black community is going through right
now and we want to spend the time on our
show today talking about that because
really nothing else is important right
now um if I else matters
no I it seems as though in our community
though there's a bit of confusion about
where we stand on this issue and so we
spoke about it a bit on Friday's episode
but there's no shortage of amount of
times that we can say that black lives
matter George Floyd's life matters and
George Floyd deserves
this um the murder of George Floyd was a
disgusting racist abuse of power and the
police officers involved must be held
responsible three out of four of the
officers involved in his murder still
have not been arrested have not been
charged and we want to use our platform
and our voices right now to seek justice
for George Floyd and to speak out
against this injustice and the ones that
have come before it because there is
systemic racism in this country and we
cannot it enact change help enact change
if we're not talking about it right and
so even though it's not necessarily a
topic we normally talk about on the
toast you and I both made a conscious
ever Essar effort excuse me to address
it on Friday's episode and I've been
posting about it on my Instagram for a
few days but there still was this sort
of um just confusion from the community
and that means that we're just not being
loud enough so I'm gonna say it now and
I'll say it again if you ever want to
know where Jackie and I stand on a
certain issue I really encourage you to
look at our instagrams our social media
our podcasts you know girl with no job
Jackie Oh problems the morning toast
those are the places if you want to hear
from us and and that's it nowhere else
Jackie and I are individuals we are
separate grown women we are responsible
for this platform and what we say on
this platform but we are not responsible
for what other people think or say we
and I can't say this enough times like
we are so sad about what has happened
this week and the murder of George Floyd
who was a man who was murdered for being
black and he was murdered at the hands
of police officers who are supposed to
be there to protect us which makes this
even more sickening and it's not the
first time that this has happened it is
indicative of a much much larger problem
in this country of police brutality and
systemic racism and I feel sad and like
embarrassed that people might not have
even known where we stood on this and
that we weren't being loud enough and
that's on us that's on us but that ends
today we want to let you guys know
exactly how we feel about this we speak
for ourselves we think for ourselves and
we are just we are so saddened by this
but we also are motivated to make a
change in the type of content that we're
sharing with you guys um I feel like uh
though in the past obviously we haven't
been the most outspoken influencers
about racial injustice and one I want to
say that we are sorry about that and two
that is ending today yeah I'm like
mortified that we even have to say that
but it's true and I feel like I've just
thought of myself as this like woke
person who's like so aware but like at
the end of the day it's just so not the
case and we have so much work to do on
ourselves and and in our community and I
feel like the word ally gets thrown
around a lot and I like to think of
myself as an ally but you can't really
be an ally unless you know like
knowledge is truly power so Jackie and I
have been spending you know the last few
days just reading and consuming as much
as we can because I don't think you can
really consider yourself an ally if you
just post something on social media and
then go on with the rest of your day
thinking that you solve the world's
problems or that you know it's over or
I'm an ally because I posted know
there's so much more that goes into
being an ally and there's so much more
work and knowledge that requires you
that that's required of you if you want
to be considered a true ally yeah and we
want to be allies we want to be part of
the solution not part of the problem and
I think that for a while you and I were
just feeling this need to prove to
people that were not racist but that's
not even enough like it's not enough to
just be not racist like we have to be
anti racism and there's a lot of
different ways that we can do that and
it starts with reading and educating and
watching things that change the way that
we see the world and help us understand
the plights of people of color and the
black community right and we'll never
we'll never really know what it's like
to be a black person in America right
now and how
challenging it can be but I think the
first step like you said in wanting to
be more of an ally and an advocate is
having those uncomfortable you know
thoughts and and really recognizing your
own privilege like you and I are white
we that makes us privileged and we don't
even think about things that other
people think about every day like I
literally was on the street a few days
ago getting I got a blood test and this
police officer came up to me was like
are you lost you know where to go when
he was like so nice and I just it given
what's going on in the world I was like
wow that's kind of weird it just really
made me so aware of my privilege and you
know we grew up a certain way I think a
lot of our audience can relate you know
growing up privileged and around
surrounded by people who were just as if
not more privileged than us but as
adults you know we've made the conscious
effort to kind of grow and evolve and
unlearn some of the biases that we might
not have even necessarily knew that we
had in our hearts like even
subconsciously like those biases just
kind of skew the way you see the world
and made us think that racial inequality
you know it wasn't our problem or it
didn't apply to us or maybe it was just
isolated incidents but now just kind of
evolving in the way that we have like I
realized that that type of thinking is
exactly what makes you part of the
problem it's still part of the problem
and I don't want to be a part of the
problem and I don't want our community
to be about a part of the problem
anymore like we need to be a part of the
solution like we have this platform and
while I know that what we do here is not
life saving work I do think that we can
make a difference yeah I think that we
can make a difference too and there's a
lot of different things that we want to
share with you today but first and for
more first and foremost we want to share
with you ways that you can take action
now help the black lives matter movement
there are a lot or of great
organizations that we've contributed to
financially that we ask that you do as
well so I'm just gonna share with you
some of those organizations that could
really benefit um from our help
financially and otherwise right now the
first organization is the George Floyd
Memorial Fund this is the official
GoFundMe to support the Floyd family
it's amazing how many people have
donated like the last time I checked it
was six million dollars and
it's obviously like nice to see so many
people just wanting to help but at the
same time it's like nothing's gonna
bring back their brother son cousin and
it just it like makes me sit like really
really sad ya know it makes me really
sad too it's just it will never be
enough
exactly also the Minnesota freedom fund
which is a community-based nonprofit
that pays criminal bail and immigration
bonds for individuals who have been
arrested while protesting police
brutality
the n-double-a-cp Legal Defense Fund
which is a legal organization that
fights for racial justice the black
visions collective which is a black
trans and queer led organization that is
committed to dismantling systems of
oppression and violence and shifting the
public narrative to create long-term
change and the Innocence Project which
exonerates the wrongly convicted through
DNA testing and reforms the criminal
justice system to prevent future
injustice yet we've linked um all the
organizations below on YouTube and on
all the podcast apps so you can learn
more about the organization click the
link donate if you can Jackie and I have
donated and then if you can um we really
would love if you guys would do that as
well know no amount is considered too
small I know it's a tough time for
everyone but I think it's really
important that we you know put our money
where our mouth is and not just say
stuff but actions speak louder than
words yeah so those are some ways that
we can help right now today and I think
it is so important to be outraged right
now
but we also need to keep up this
momentum within ourselves within our
community and make changes that will
help us just get out of our bubble and
become more educated about the plight of
the black community and just their
experiences yeah like how we move
forward needs to obviously benefit and
educate ourselves but also our community
and of course you know we are so divided
in this country right now and again this
is a pop culture show it's meant to be
fun and light and while I don't think
we're gonna you know change the world in
a day I think there are definitely
things we could be doing within
ourselves just to broaden and
widen our knowledge and our experience
like so many people come on this show
and they watch TV shows or they read
books or they go see movies that we
recommend and I feel like for a while
maybe without even realizing we were
just like our content was just so
narrow-minded and it was like we leave
this bubble and everything we watch is
like just all the same and I feel like a
really great place to start and
educating ourselves is just with the
content you watch like there are so many
movies and TV shows
directed by starring people of color and
that we've kind of just been ignoring
yeah I completely agree some of the
stuff that we've recommended has been a
complete waste of your time our time
like Dinner for Schmucks
I take Cannes that time [ __ ] that time
can be where the Schmucks well are the
Schmucks like we are wasting people's
time and not really taking advantage of
what we actually could be watching and
learning right so we want to spend our
time and your time more thoughtfully we
will never understand what it is like to
be a black person in this country but we
can listen to people we can watch movies
we can watch TV shows we can read books
that will help us see the world
differently than how we've been seeing
it oh you know I know that the next
redheads book is going to be very
different from what we've been reading
and I think that it is time for that to
happen and we want to use the our
suggestions our recommendations our
influence to help all of us get a better
sense of what is going on in the world
so we're not just waking up one game
waking up to all of it right like even
though will never understand the
experience just watching stuff and
reading stuff is a real window into the
experiences of people who are different
from us and that's important and I feel
like we haven't been doing that and I
really I do apologize for that so with
that said we are bringing back to its
movie of the week here on the morning
toast but it's gonna be slightly
different as it pertains to the content
that we choose which i think is long
overdue we just want to watch stuff that
makes us more aware of our privilege and
end of our platform and make sure that
we're encouraging people
watch things that are slightly more
important then you know the invention of
lying so toast movie of the week is
coming back we want to highlight stories
that are important to watch that are
directed by or starring people of color
that tells their story just so we can
you know have a better understanding of
the world and just racism in general um
the first movie that we're assigning
today that we will recap at the end of
this week is called the hate you give it
is available on Hulu so if you have a
Hulu you could watch it for free if you
don't have one make sure to steal a
friend's mom you can watch it for free
there it's been highly recommended all
over social media I've been seeing
people watch it so I think that'll just
it's it's a good place to start it's a
good place to start
um I look forward to watching it with
you Claud with as many toasters as
possible I look forward to the
discussions we will have about it and I
look forward to continuing this on well
after this week also something that we
want to do is we are going to be using
our Friday episodes we will be using all
of our ad space from those episodes to
promote black businesses black owned
businesses we think that that is just
one small way that we can help raise
awareness for great businesses that you
guys should know about that we should
know about that we should be shopping
out we have some great ones in mind but
if you guys want to suggest some more we
would love to take your suggestions and
incorporate that into the show yeah I
really encourage everyone to reach out
if they have businesses that they think
could benefit from being highlighted on
the show if they're a toaster owned
business just anything to kind of raise
awareness I think that'll be just an
again just an expand beyond our own
experiences and our own bubble and our
own knowledge because that's what we've
been doing like for so long and it's
never been more apparent and it's like
it's embarrassing yeah it's important
that we do it and it's time that we do
it and we are sorry that um it took this
it's taken it's taken us this long but
we've just been spending the weekend
just reading and seeing and trying to
understand what how we can better
educate ourselves and we
take those points you know that everyone
has been sharing and actually implement
them into this show yes we are a pop
culture show we will continue to be a
pop culture show but there's a lot of
ways that we can be doing better within
the confines of our show right we will
continue to be a pop culture show with a
better understanding of our platform of
our influence and of the world around us
specifically of people who don't look
like us yeah I I agree yeah
I'm sure that a lot of people tuned in
today to hear if we have to anything to
say about this like some of the Facebook
drama that happened
yeah um honestly really nothing feels
less important than talking about
Facebook group drama today we know that
some of the subgroups changed their
names and we think that that's great for
them these subgroups were made for you a
lot of them were made by you and if you
want to change the name of your group go
right ahead
that works for us yeah I don't really
want to make it a whole hoopla because
in the grand scheme of the world it's
just not important and I want and I want
to continue just to dedicate their time
on the show to things that are worthy
and George Floyd and the entire black
lives matter movement is worthy of that
so which is also I there's no fast five
stories today it just doesn't feel right
or appropriate um I think that we all
need to be spending this time learning
more and watching you know videos
consuming content that will help us get
a better understanding of what's going
on in supporting the black lives matter
movement right now um I think that a lot
of times our show is is a welcome
distraction for people from what might
be going on in their lives or what's
going on in the world and we love that
we love that and that's what we do and
that is what that is our purpose you
know to just make light of tough
situations and help everyone get through
but then there are some times where is
important to not be distracted from
what's going on and we feel as though
today is one of those
time's right like we as a community have
been distracted long enough and I think
it's just time that we take this
seriously so we apologize for there not
being an episode we promise we will be
back you know later in the week but I
just felt and Jackie and felt that out
of respect for the lives lost and just
for the entire movement um just to not
just to not just to not so we hope
everyone is doing well um and we'll see
you tomorrow we'll see ya